hey do you remember that carrier plant
in Indiana that Donald Trump and Mike
Pence heroically were able to save early
and Donald Trump's presidency he touted
it as this major victory for his
economic policy even though it wasn't
actually policy it was just giving one
company money to stay in Indiana it was
a handout right so that this one company
would keep some jobs in Indiana but we
knew it was bogus and in fact we heard
from the company that the money would be
used short-term to automate the factory
and reduce jobs in the long term and
carrier previously announced that you
know even though we got that tax break I
call it a bribe we're still gonna be
doing some layoffs they've now announced
that 215 more employees are going to be
laid off because their jobs are going to
Mexico 300 jobs were eliminated back in
July
215 more jobs being eliminated now Chuck
Jones the former president of the local
union in Indianapolis said that he's
worried about more layoffs coming in the
future and of course more layoffs are
coming in the future carrier said that
the big picture of the money they got
from Trump was going to be used to
automate factories which in the long
term is going to reduce employment make
America great again right and I was
thinking about how there's often there's
usually at least one snake oil salesman
in every primary but usually they don't
win right they only last for the
beginning of the primary this time it
just so happened that the snake oil
salesman that was in the Republican
primary not only won the primary but
became President of the United States
and depending on how these blue-collar
workers in the Midwest respond to this
bamboozling by Trump it might actually
help turn some of those Midwestern
states blue in upcoming elections we
know that cognitive dissonance prevents
a lot of these voters from admitting to
themselves that they were tricked and
sometimes they become even more
entrenched in their beliefs but it would
be great if at least their job loss
which is horrible and tragic could be
turned into something positive by making
them say you know what we were tricked
fool me one
shame on fool me twice you don't get
fooled again at a good point right and
that they don't vote for Donald Trump in
2020 is the point that I'm getting to
and of course by the way remember that
as their severance --is elapsed a lot of
these people that are being laid off
despite Donald Trump giving a tax break
to carrier they're gonna get on public
assistance they're gonna start
qualifying for a lot of the programs
that Trump ist's say we need to be
pulling money from it's just a circle
it's a comedy of errors and long term
what we know is that a one-time cash
hand out to a company is not going to
change the company's plans it's still
cheaper to go to Mexico they're still
automating jobs in the future the
business environment of Indiana has not
fundamentally changed because Trump said
hey take some money and at least say
that for now you're gonna keep the pack
the factory here it's not policy well I
think some trumpets would look at this
and say that this is anecdotal right
it's just one example and it's not any
broader implication of his wider
economic policy or the tax plan you know
what I would say to that when they say
hey look because of the tax plan here's
two companies that are giving employees
bonuses that's when I would say that's
anecdotal all businesses got the tax
breaks and 0.00001 percent of them are
choosing to give their employees bonuses
as a result that's anecdotal not this
this is just kind of obvious because
it's not actually economic policy